do you think AGI could be achieved with
a neural network as we understand them
today yes
I'll just flatly last yes the question
is whether the current architecture of
stacking more Transformer layers which
probably know gpt4 is no longer doing
because they're not telling us the
architecture which is a correct decision
oh correct decision I had a conversation
with Sam Altman will return to this
topic a few times
he turned the question to me
of how open should open AI be about GPT
for would you open source the code he
asked me
because I provided as criticism saying
that while I do appreciate transparency
open AI could be more open
and he says we struggle with this
question what would you do change their
name to closed Ai and like
cell gpt4 to business back-end
applications that don't expose it to
Consumers and Venture capitalists and
create a ton of hype and like pour a
bunch of new funding into the area like
too late now but don't you think others
would do it
eventually you shouldn't do it first
like if if you already have giant
nuclear stockpiles don't build more
if some other country starts building a
larger nuclear stockpile than sure build
then you know
even then maybe just have enough nukes
you know there's a these things are not
quite like nuclear weapons they spit out
gold until they get large enough and
then ignite the atmosphere and kill
everybody
um
and there is something to be said for
not destroying the world with your own
hands even if you can't stop somebody
else from doing it
but but open sourcing it now that that's
just sheer catastrophe oh the whole
notion of open sourcing this was always
the wrong approach the wrong ideal there
are there are places in the world where
open source is a noble ideal and
building stuff you don't understand that
is difficult to control that where if
you could align it it would take time
you'd have to spend a bunch of time
doing it that is that is not a place for
open source because then you just have
like powerful things that just like go
straight out the gate without anybody
having had the time to have them not
kill everyone
so can we still man the case for
some level of transparency and openness
maybe open sourcing
so the case could be that because gpt4
is not close to AGI if that's the case
that this does allow open sourcing
you're being open about the architecture
being transparent about maybe research
and investigation of how the thing works
of all the different aspects of it of
its behavior of its structure of of its
training processes if the data was
trained on everything like that that
allows us to gain a lot of insights
about alignment about the alignment
problem to do really good AI Safety
Research while the system is not too
powerful can you make that case that it
could be a resource I do not believe in
the practice of Steel Manning there's
something to be said for trying to pass
the ideological Turing test where you
describe
your opponent's position uh the disagree
disagreeing person's position well
enough that somebody cannot tell the
difference between your description and
their description
but steel Manning no like okay well this
is where you and I disagree here that's
interesting why don't you believe in
steel Manning I do not want okay so for
one thing if somebody's trying to
understand me I do not want them steel
Manning my position I want them to
describe to to like try to describe my
position the way I would describe it not
what they think is an improvement
well I I think that is what
steel Manning is is the most charitable
interpretation I I don't want to be
interpreted charitably I want them to
understand what I'm actually saying if
they go off into the land of charitable
interpretations they're like often their
land of like
the thing the stuff they're imagining
and not trying to understand my own
Viewpoint anymore well I'll put it
differently then just to push on this
point I would say it is restating what I
think you understand
under the empathetic assumption that
Eliezer is brilliant
and have honestly and rigorously thought
about the point he has made right so if
there's two possible interpretations of
what I'm saying and one interpretation
is really stupid and whack and doesn't
sound like me and doesn't fit with the
rest of what I've been saying and one
interpretation you know sounds like some
like something a reasonable person who
believes the rest of what I believe
would also say go with the second
interpretation that's steel Manning
that's that's a good guess
if on the other hand you like there's
like
something that sounds completely whack
and something that sounds like a little
less completely whack but you don't see
why I would believe in it doesn't fit
with the other stuff I say but you know
that sounds like less whack and you can
like sort of see you could like maybe
argue it then you probably have not
understood it see okay I'm gonna this is
fun because I'm gonna Linger on this you
know you wrote a brilliant blog post AJ
I ruined a list of lethalities right and
it was a bunch of different points and I
would say that some of the points are
bigger and more powerful than others if
you were to sort them you probably could
you personally and to me steel Manning
means like going through the different
arguments and finding the ones that are
really the most like
powerful if people like tldr
like what should you be most concerned
about and bringing that up in a strong
uh compelling eloquent way these are the
points that elieza would make to to make
the case in this case that hey it's
gonna kill all of us but that that
that's what steel Manning is presenting
it in a really nice way the summary of
my best understanding of your
perspective that because to me there's a
sea of possible presentations of your
perspective and steel Manning is doing
your best to do the best one in that sea
of different perspectives do you believe
it
do I believe in what like these things
that you would be presenting as like the
strongest version of my perspective do
you believe what you would be presenting
do you think it's true
I I'm a big proponent of empathy when I
see the perspective of a person
there is a part of me that believes it
if I understand it and you have
especially in political discourse in
geopolitics I've been hearing a lot of
different perspectives on the world
and I hold my own opinions but I also
speak to a lot of people that have a
very different life experience and a
very different set of beliefs
and I think there has to be epistemic
humility
in
in stating what is true so when I
empathize with another person's
perspective there is a sense in which I
believe it is true
I I think probabilistically I would say
in the way you think about do you bet
money on it
and do you bet money on their beliefs
when you believe them
are we allowed to do probability
sure you can State a probability of that
yes there's there's a loose there's a
probability there's a there's a
probability and I I think empathy is
allocating a non-zero probability to
believe
in some sense for time
if you've got someone on your show who
believes in the abrahamic deity
classical style somebody on the show
who's a young Earth creationist do you
say I put a probability on it then
that's my empathy
when you reduce beliefs into
probabilities it starts to get you know
we can even just go to Flat Earth is the
earth flat
because I think it's a little more
difficult nowadays to find people who
believe that unironically but
fortunately
I think well it's hard to know an ironic
yeah from ironic uh but I think there's
quite a lot of people that believe that
yeah it's
there's a space of argument where you're
operating in irrationally in the space
of ideas but then there's also
a kind of discourse where you're
operating in the space of
subjective experiences and life
experiences like
I think what it means to be human is
more than just
searching for truth
it's just operating of what is true and
what is not true I think there has to be
deep humility that we humans are very
limited in our ability to understand
what is true
so what probabilities do you assign to
the young Earth's creationists beliefs
then
I think I have to give non-zero out of
your humility yeah but like
three
I think I would uh it would be
irresponsible for me to give a number
because the The Listener the way the
human mind works
we're not good at hearing the
probabilities
right you hear three what is what is
three exactly right they're going to
hear they're going to like well there's
only three probabilities I feel like
zero fifty percent and a hundred percent
in the human mind or something like this
right well zero forty percent and a
hundred percent is a bit closer to it
based on what happens to chat GPT after
RL H effort to speak humanies this is
brilliant uh yeah this is It's really
interesting I didn't I didn't know those
negative side effects of rohf that's
fascinating but uh just to uh return to
the
open AI close there also like a quick
disclaimer I'm doing all this for memory
I'm not pulling out my phone to look it
up it is entirely possible that the
things I'm saying are wrong so thank you
for that disclaimer so uh uh and thank
you for
what being willing to be wrong
that's beautiful to hear
I think being willing to be wrong is a
sign of a person who's done a lot of
thinking about this world and
has been humbled by the mystery and the
complexity of this world and I think
a lot of us are resistant to admitting
we're wrong because it hurts it hurts
personally
it hurts especially when you're a public
human it hurts publicly because people
uh
people point out every time you're wrong
like look you change your mind you're
hypocrite you're uh an idiot whatever
whatever they want to say oh I block
those people and then I never hear from
them again on Twitter
well the point is uh the point is to not
let that pressure public pressure affect
your mind and be willing to be in the
privacy of your mind
to contemplate
the possibility that you're wrong and
the possibility that you're wrong about
the most fundamental things you believe
like people who believe in a particular
God or people who believe that their
nation is the greatest nation on Earth
but all those kinds of beliefs that
Accord to who you are when you come up
to raise that point to yourself in the
privacy of your mind and say maybe I'm
wrong about this that's a really
powerful thing to do and especially when
you're somebody who's thinking about uh
topics that can uh about systems that
can destroy human civilization or maybe
help with flourish so thank you thank
you for being willing to be wrong
about open AI
so you really
I just would love to linger on this you
really think it's wrong to open source
it I think that burns the time remaining
until everybody dies I think we are not
on track
to learn remotely near fast enough
even if it were open sourced
um yeah that's
I it's easier to think that you might be
wrong about something when being wrong
about something is the
is the only way that there's hope
and
it doesn't seem very likely to me that
that particular thing I'm wrong about is
that this is a great time to open source
GPT for
if Humanity was trying to survive at
this point in the straightforward way it
would be like
shutting down the big GPU clusters
no more giant runs
it's questionable whether we should even
be throwing gpt4 around although that is
a matter of conservatism rather than a
matter of my predicting that catastrophe
will follow from gpd4 that is something
which I put like a pretty low
probability
but also like when I when I say like I
put a low probability on it I can feel
myself reaching into the part of myself
that thought that gpt4 was not possible
in the first place so I do not trust
that part as much as I used to
like the trick is not just to say I'm
wrong but like okay well I was I was
wrong about that like can I get out
ahead of that curve and like predict the
next thing I'm going to be wrong about
so the set of assumptions or the actual
reasoning system that you were
leveraging in making that initial
statement prediction
uh how can you adjust that to make
better predictions about GPT four five
six you don't want to keep on being
wrong in a predictable Direction yeah
that like being wrong anybody has to do
that walking through the world there's
like no way you don't say 90 and
sometimes be wrong in fact adap at least
one time out of ten if you're well
calibrated when you say 90 percent
the the undignified thing is not being
wrong it's being predictably wrong it's
being wrong in the same direction over
and over again
so having been wrong about how far
neural networks would go and having been
wrong specifically about whether gpt4
would be as impressive as it is when I
like when I say like well I don't
actually think gpt4 causes a catastrophe
I do feel myself relying on that part of
me that was previously wrong and that
does not mean that the answer is now in
the opposite direction reverse stupidity
is not intelligence
but it does mean that I that I say it
with a
with the worry note in my voice it's
like still my guess but like you know
it's a place where I was wrong maybe you
should be asking guern branwin guern
branwin has been like writer about this
than I have maybe you ask him if you
think if if he thinks it's dangerous
rather than asking me
I think there's a lot of mystery about
what intelligence is
what a GI looks like
so I think all of us are rapidly
adjusting our model but the point is to
be rapidly adjusting the model versus
having a model that was right in the
first place I do not feel that seeing
Bing has changed my model of what
intelligence is it has changed my
understanding of what kind of work can
be performed by which kind of processes
and by which means does not change my
understanding of the work there's a
difference between thinking that the
right flyer can't fly and then like it
does fly and you're like oh well I guess
you can do that with wings with
fixed-wing aircraft and being like Oh
it's flying this changes my picture of
what the very substance of flight is
that's like a stranger update to make
and Bing has not yet updated me in that
way
um yeah that uh the laws of physics
are actually wrong that kind of update
no no like just like oh like I Define
intelligence this way but I now see that
was a stupid definition I don't feel
like the way that things have played out
over the last 20 years has caused me to
feel that way